in this episode of cloud performance
analyst I take a look at the right way
to profile a CDN will our latency hit
the mark stay tuned to find out in a
previous episode we talked about how the
Google cloud load balancer can be
supercharged to leverage CDN
capabilities for faster content
distribution to your users which of
course kicked off a discussion with
multiple developers about the nuances of
CDN performance and how Google's stacked
up now the minimum functionality for a
CDN is caching a requested asset closer
to users so that future requests have
the lowest possible latency to see what
this looks like performance wise we
simply set up an asset on the CDN and
fetched it via a curl command about 500
times or so you know things are working
properly when your graph looks something
like this you see a bunch of slower
requests at the front of your timeline
and then latency dropped significantly
once the caching occurs if you run the
same test but from various instances
distributed globally you'll get
something that looks like this we placed
an asset on a server in Texas and
fetched it from various points around
the world you can see how Google's edge
Network properly cached the asset and
moved it closer to the user for later
fetches now oh by the way if you're
super interested you can modify your
curl command to spit out all the sub
sections of those requests and graph
those individually things like DNS
resolve time connection and pre transfer
speeds can vary between CDN providers so
it's sometimes nice to see how these
things break out so that you can compare
them properly now sadly these tests show
a rough estimate of performance but to
really show off the power of Google CDN
you need to write a bigger test for
example the cloud team built a test
using Vegeta running on Google container
engine which allowed each pod to scale
up to about 50,000 RPS and an even
bigger test has been done by the
Sodexo's radar community which collects
over 14 billion real user measurements
each day from users all around the world
across providers which means that you
can compare them and see which one works
for your situation if you're interested
in more information on either of those
tests check out the article for this
video linked in the description below
where you can also find more great ideas
on how to optimize your cloud
performance because when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts